[Music]  bachelor in paradise season 5 cast  revealed  [Music]  the new season will be jam-packed with  bachelor nation fan favorites including  a firecracker  Bibiana from re season I'm so hopeful  grocery store Joe from Becca's a fun  fact about myself I never forget a face  and the always inspiring Eric bigger  from Rachael Lindsey season of The  Bachelorette  when we stay open in life you can this  burn some amazing things will also  finally get to see the much-anticipated  proposal between Jared Haven and Ashley  I can Eddie  we're definitely engaged we are we are  very happy first there were tears I  think we can say that that's kind of a  dead giveaway after a scandal filled  fourth season The Bachelor spin-off will  return for its fifth August seventh  [Music]